So, sometimes we find ourselves faced
with, really hard software testing problems.
Let me go over some of the characteristics of this problem. Lack
of a specification is common, or perhaps only, lack of a good
specification. If there are no comparable implementations of the kind of system
we're implementing, that is to say of the first system of its
sort, that makes testing quite hard. Because what it probably means is
we are debugging the specification or even developing the specification as we
go. Big systems are hard to test, large highly structured input spaces,
like testing quite hard and so if you want to imagine sort
of a hard testing problem with a large highly structured input space.
Consider for example, the flight control computer is on a space craft
or an airplane, these things take sort of an enormous variety of input
from all sort of different redundant sensors. The time at which these inputs
arrive is significant. The spacecraft or the airplane has all sorts of
physical properties likes its altitude, its
attitude, the positions of various control
surfaces that all affected dynamics. These kind of systems are really, really,
sort of truly hard to test. Non-determinism can make a system very hard
to test. And, the issue here is that, we'll play a test case
against the system once, and it succeeds. But then, at some later time,
some variable that's not under our control will cause the system to fail on
that same input. Lots of hidden statement make systems hard to test. Some
systems that I've heard of either extremely hard to test or for example, Java
Virtual Machine. That are run by,
for example, financial organizations on lots of
cores with huge amounts of memory. These things have so, so much internal state,
that when something goes wrong, it's almost
impossible to make any inferences about what
was going on inside of it. And, you end up needing to try to
reproduce the problem. But, of course, this
is also extremely hard because the problem
probably happened Three hours into some sort
of a massive processing task. Finally, if
we lack strong oracles testing can be
really hard. And so, for example, something
like a large molecular simulation might be very hard to test. So ,we have
some sort of a new simulation code, we have no idea what the right
answer is supposed to be probably. It's running on some sort of a large
parallel machine, so we have a very hard time reproducing problems. Problems
might take a long time to occur, something like an autopilot might be
extremely hard to test, because the response of the thing is going to
be inherently in terms of the stability. And good behavior of the airplane.
And of course this is an incredibly large complex physical object that's
very hard to model and simulate in a reliable fashion. If you think
about picking a strong test for
an autopilot, it's almost inconceivable. Okay, like
I said, some sort of a giant JVM running with lots of cores
for a long time using a huge amount of heat. Very, very hard to
test the behavior of something in that kind of a state. So, the question we
want to ask ourselves is, how do we get a handle on these situations?
How should we test these things? And
often, there aren't really any easy answers. But
what we can do is, we can, leverage weak oracles to the maximum extent
possible if any of these things, the
simulation, the auto-pilot or the JVM actually crashes
in a bad fashion. Then we definitely know something's gone wrong. We can try to
bootstrap some degree of confidence in the
software under test by taking small test inputs.
For which we've hand-checked the output and trying to argue that, for example,
somehow, the auto-pilot if it responds well for these inputs also responds well
for other test inputs. And in the end, if we're thwarted in our
attempts to do really good testing, we probably have to rely on non-testing
methods. And so, of course we, we should be doing code inspections and
using formal methods on our systems in any case, if we care about
the reliability. But what's happening here, if we really can't test the system
effectively, we might have to rely on these things more than we would've liked.
Okay, so that's just a quick survey of,
things that can make testing really hard in practice.